embattled Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu is vowing to stay in
office as he fights charges of fraud
bribery and breach of trust
Israel's Attorney General announced his
intent to indict Netanyahu yesterday
less than two months before elections he
would be the first sitting Israeli Prime
Minister to face criminal charges Seth
Doane is following developments from
London South good morning good morning
in a fiery speech that outlined his
defense that he didn't do it and is the
victim of a witch hunt Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu took a decidedly
political tone just six weeks before
Israel's election he noted his place on
the world stage with friends including
Russia's Vladimir Putin and President
Trump a reminder that he's been in power
for more than a decade he called the
planned indictment political persecution
the three cases alleged that he offered
regulatory benefits in exchange for
favorable news coverage that he traded
legislation that could damage one
newspaper for good press in another and
that he and his wife had accepted gifts
totaling more than a quarter of a
million dollars of cigars champagne and
jewelry all in exchange for political
favors for a Hollywood producer
Netanyahu will get the chance to defend
himself in a hearing before the
indictment is official that date has not
yet been set but it's expected to be
after the April 9th election Alex thank
you